From the Library of Congress and the Smithsonian National Museum of African American History and Culture.
Today is Saturday, March 9, 2013. My name is Will Griffin and I'm a research associate with the Southern Oral History Program at the University of North Carolina at Chapel Hill.
I am with videographer John Bishop and Albany Georgia on the campus of Albany State University to conduct an interview for the Civil Rights History Project, which is a joint undertaking of the Smithsonian National Museum of African American History and Culture and the Library of Congress.
We are here with Miss Louise Broadway who played a prominent role in the local Baker County Movement.
Thank you so much for being here Miss Broadway and agreeing to share your story with the Civil Rights History Project.
You're welcome. If we could just begin by giving your full name, your date of birth and your place of birth.
I'm Louise, with in Hamborough, I was born in Baker County, Georgia, a little town known as Newton.
I was born in 1930, 86, 86 in 1930.
Let's talk about your childhood growing up. My childhood, experiencing growing up, I was re-appointed. My parents were a farmer, they did not have a farm.
We did not have school buses at the time that I was growing up. We had to walk to school to church. We had schools in church. We had to walk to school in the cold every morning.
Some mornings it was so very cold, you could hardly feel your feelings in your hands when you get to school but they had an old potbelly stone that they would fire up and we would gather around and get warm.
That was my childhood experience of school.
Did you just think that the schools, the conditions of your schools, those were normal? Did you notice the conditions of white schools?
The children would pass us on the school bus, they would drive the school and we would have to walk the school.
Regardless of your distance, some tiering, which is 10 or 15 miles to get to the church and yet the white children on the white buses would pass by them living in the same neighborhood.
But we could not ride the bus and my childhood growing up is good.
So what about your experiences in school, your teachers? Do you remember any of your favorite teachers?
I remember my teachers, one of them was Miss Salome, and one was Miss Mary, Hawkins.
We taught in the church and inside the church, you didn't have any petitions between the class rooms. They would take about three pews, first grade, and they taught from the first through the seventh.
In the same sanctuary. And the same sanctuary, one teacher, not one for each class.
And they would have a section for the first grade, second, third, fourth, fifth, up through seventh.
That's amazing. And you had to keep quiet. You wouldn't be disturbing the teacher while she was teaching from one class to another she had a time for each one.
You know, time for the class. And that is the way we really got a good education though. Right now I can appreciate those days.
They were hot, not having heat and having to try to be quiet and listen. But we made it.
And I graduated from left to seventh grade then I went to high school. High school was down in Newton. They had a, it was two high schools. One was in the east and one was in the west for the black people.
So they had two Newton colored high schools. That's right. They had a, that's right. And which one did you attend?
Well, I went to Newton colored high school. They did not, when I was in high school, they just added the west Baker high school after my graduating from Newton colored high school.
And what was Newton colored high school like? I mean, what's it? We had a fun neighborhood. They were had baritps, army baritps. Maybe I guess they were thrown in by the state.
And they had baritps that we would go in from class to class. And they had had one little building that they call like a, I was chapel in the homemade department.
And that's where we had chapel and homemade department in one building. And then the other baritps we had different classes the teachers had them at different times.
So where are you two? Okay. So were you an only child? Did you? No, I'm the youngest of four. Of four? Okay. So what was your relationship like with your older brothers? Is it the white chapter you and the baby?
Well, I think they spoiled me because I was the youngest. I only had one brother and two sisters. And growing up the second child, which sister, she never did want me to do anything. She every time it was time for my choice for anything. She would always like to do on five minutes because she loved me so.
And I think it kind of spoiled me when she left home. Then I had chose to do that. She had to do five minutes. It was kind of hard. But we were a lovely family and we lived in a one room country shack.
We had a bed for mother and father, bed for the girls and one for the boys. I am one kitchen, one kitchen, no dining area. But believe it or not, we made it and had open five plays. You were burnt up in front and freeze.
But we made it through. We had a joyous childhood together under the circumstances.
So what do you remember about your parents the most besides them being hard workers? What type of lessons that they seek to steal?
My parent and still in me that we had to learn to end do with what we had.
Regardless of what somebody else had, what they could afford to give us, they learned us to appreciate that.
We had to go to Sunday school, we had to go to church, air a Sunday. And we had to put church first regardless of school activities or whatnot.
You had to go to church before you go to school activities. And they fed us. It might have been just meeting for it. But we never went hungry.
We never went hungry. My father worked at a grist meal. You know, were they grinded meal?
Grist meal.
Yeah. That's where they would take corn and grind it up to make meal.
Okay.
And that's where my father worked. And my mother worked as a maid from house to house.
Okay. Okay.
So let's go back to high school. Would you graduate from high school in what year?
1948. 1948. And what were your plans? I mean, did you know?
Well, really, really, and truly, my plans were to go to college.
Okay. But at that time, my father, I told you that was a sharecropper and my mother worked. And they was working from 50% to $1 a day.
And at that time, nowhere in the world, you know, they could send me away and away to school.
So they just, they were not able to send me away to school. So my first job was working as a maid in the kitchen working for a dollar a day.
Okay. Who were you working for? Do you remember the family you worked for?
Me, a guy.
And what, do you remember who, what, what was the name of the family that you worked for?
Oh, the name of the family was, was Mamie McConnell.
Mamie McConnell.
McConnell, MC.
MC.
C-O-R-R-A-L-I-B-D.
Okay.
Okay. So, what, what?
Well, Mamie White. I'm sorry. No, it was. Her name was Mamie White. I'm sorry.
Her name was Mamie White, not Mamie McConnell. But you and they Mamie White. That's who I worked for.
And how was it, her treatment, their treatment of you?
Yeah. They treated you well?
They were, they were, they were very nice. I had to walk.
We lived about five miles from where they lived. And I would walk here morning to clean house and fix dinner and, you know, do whatever house tools that were to do.
Okay.
They, they, they were very nice people.
And how long did you do this? I mean, for how long?
I worked as a, uh, made for about a year after I finished high school.
Okay.
And then I got married. I finished high school in 1940.
I got married in 1949.
Who was your husband? How did you?
My husband was a grader.
Broadway junior.
And how'd you meet Grady? How did you meet Grady?
How did I meet him?
Well, now, the way I met Grady, I had a cousin, or I guess the name been called Carl Broadway.
He married my cousin, one of my cousins.
And I would often go spend the weekend with this cousin.
And Grady's oldest brother was rearing him because their parents passed away early.
Okay.
And, uh, way back in the, and we were very young.
We would see one another smile about it and never thought one day we would get together.
And to be husband and wife.
Now, that's how we first thought, you know, just being around one another,
and his father would bring him the church.
And my mother would bring me the church.
We just smiled at one another.
So, in the late, parties, he moved up in the community where I live.
And that's why we, how we got back together.
Just old friends got back together.
And one day, he asked me to marry, and I married him.
And we had five children together.
Five children?
I was second children, two, and two.
Oh, wow.
Okay.
So, yeah, the house full.
And yes?
Yes.
We maintained.
So, talk about the racial conditions in Baker County.
When did you first start noticing or, you know, begin to...
Well, really, as a child, I noticed race so far as the wife's being able to ride the school bus.
Okay, that was the first thing.
And blacks walk in the cold, and they, you know,
patients through our spitballs or whatever, we walking from a school.
Now, I noticed that, you know, as my, in my childhood.
How did you feel about that?
Did you think that that was just the way it was, or did you feel it was unfair?
Oh, at the beginning, I knew it was unfair.
You know, but it wasn't a thing I could do about it.
Right.
When it didn't think I could do about it, but I knew that was unfair.
But, you know, that was the way it was then, and we had to accept it.
So, going to high school, well, they had the Newton high school.
That was the white school, the Newton color high school.
So, you know, we never crossed each other past at that time.
But then later, on down in the years, when the Civil Rights Act was passed,
and time, you know, for children, these segregated schools, I would say, like that.
Okay.
Okay, then, my family, I had merit, then, and had children of my own.
When this got started.
1950s.
So, at the time, my husband was working for a Jane Robert Rose as a shell cropper.
Okay.
And we signed our first child, which was the eldest, Jesse Lee Broadway, to the all white school.
So, when James Robert Rose heard about, we had signed the child to go, then he told my husband that if he didn't withdraw his name,
then he was going to have to pay him everything.
He owed him before the end of the year.
You see, you got your pay at the end of the year.
So, we had to withdraw.
I was the son from the white school, you know, raised you from the white school until the end of that year.
Right.
At the end of that year, my husband stopped working for this farmer.
The next year, we were able to send three children to the end of the grade school.
But it was not easy.
Yeah, do you think that was sort of a widespread intimidation tactic?
Yeah, it was.
One of my sons was beaten so bad that he had to be hospitalized.
At school?
I mean, at school.
They brought him home that evening.
We had to bring him up to the doctor.
And he was hit so many bruises and he had to be hospitalized.
So, what happened?
Do you know that you ever talk about what exactly transpired?
Or they just again, of the white boys just jumped on them and just beat them up, stomping them, kicking them.
And he had to be hospitalized for a few days.
They would follow our children.
At this time, you know, we were busses then.
But they would follow our children home again.
Or whites would follow our children home.
When they get off the bus, they would attack them.
And I worked in Albany.
When they attacked them at school, then I got a call at work and I was driving an old pimp.
And I was driving so fast, the speed off the chain broke, trying to get home to my children.
Right.
You know, to protect them from the group that was attacking them.
Okay.
And it was very hard for us, you know, to see your child, you didn't know whether or not they was going to make it back home alive or not.
But we know somebody had to stand up.
You know, if all of us had backed up, you know, we wouldn't have had.
We wouldn't have been far as we are today.
We're not where we should be.
But it's better than it was, you know, at that time.
Sure.
So did anything ever happen to the group of boys?
Nothing happened to the group of boys.
But they did start patrolling the campus better around the school.
They had someone outside to try and keep these kind of events from happening again.
So now you said that you were working in Albany when this happened?
I worked for a medical doctor as a doctor's system for 30 years.
And this same doctor that saturday doing the marchin in the demonstration down in Baker County,
they had what you call this bloody Saturday.
Bloody Saturday.
And some of these civil right workers and some of the citizens that was beaten up so bad,
they brought some of them to Dr. J. L. Shirley's doing an office where I worked to be treated.
He treated several just treated them for free.
Several of the freedom writers and the citizens who was beaten by the mob on that bloody Saturday.
They carried some to Camilla and Camilla refused to take in of them.
So they had to bring them to Albany or take them to all of them or some other place other than Camilla.
And so you were there when they were bringing these people in?
Oh yes, I was working for the doctor at that time.
Sherrod was one of the persons that they brought in, you know, all banged and bruised.
So did you know Sherrod at that time?
Well, only by yes because I lived in Baker County and the movement was in progress at that time.
So how did you respond?
What did you think?
Oh, I just thought how cruel it was.
You know, they said they had axhounds and knives and baseball bats and guns and St. Matthew's missionary about this church of where I'm a member.
This is where they had to regroup and go back to the church and they had to lie down.
One of the pews and things because they was fine shots at the mid to church on that bloody Saturday.
And a lot of the churches around Baker County were attacked because they were holding meetings.
That's right.
That's where we had our meetings.
I was one of the secretaries of the Baker County movement.
Talk about that.
In your position as secretary, but you aren't taking notes.
What else did you do?
What type of inside information do you have that could help us understand a little more?
Well, what I would try to understand what each and every one of the citizens would get up and express themselves about certain things that happen.
I would tell you know, doing the day or the night, I would have to take notes of the happenings.
What did you do with these notes?
What happened to them?
Believe it or not, I have some of them.
I have some of them down in the library.
And at East Baker Historical Society down in Newton, right now, I was looking at some of the notes that I took where one parent was saying, one of his children got hit side to head with a stick or all this kind of stuff.
And then we would have the civil rights people that some of them come down just as I would say.
And listen to some of the complaints and all of the citizens have badly treated in order to try to make things better.
We just wanted equal opportunities.
See, we had to use the books that the whites used one year, then the next year maybe, when the books were worn and all torn.
And those are the books that we get at our schools.
And we just knew that wasn't justice.
And all the things we wanted equal opportunities, wasn't so much to integrate, you know, but if they just only had given us a chance to have materials, the wood with our children, that they had, we think we would have had better opportunities to become better men and women and educated men and women.
And the society.
All right, so you talked about the bloody sanity and civil rights work as being brought into the doctor's office.
So I take it, the doctor wasn't one who was against what was taking place.
Did you think that he supported the movement? You say his name was doctor.
And he was the J. L. Shirley Jr.
Shirley Jr.
And so did you think he supported what was taking place?
Oh, I think he really supported treating the ones that was injured and all of the blood is saddering.
He was dealing with all, he didn't, he didn't want to be reluctant at all about treating them bad.
Like some of the doctors, called C like I said, they took them to the commis, but they were not treating them.
And he was glad to be able to.
And did he know that you were somewhat involved in the movement?
Yes, he knew, he knew.
And during my time in working with Dr. Shirley, they offered a course down in Baker County, the commissioners offered a free course to take on emergency care.
They ride on the ambulance, you know, they have to see about our people.
And they have no blacks worked on the ambulance at that time.
And I would work at Dr. Shirley's office, get off at five o'clock and at night I took this course in emergency medicine.
And I was, you know, one of the first, I was the first black really to complete the course in the kind of, and work at night.
I was called on duty, maybe 11 o'clock and had to be the doctor's office around nine in the morning.
But I just felt like we needed to try to help our people.
And since the opportunity was offered to try and help other than other people having to help your people all the time,
whether or not, don't know whether we were going to get justice, you know, I felt that we had someone of our color to help with our color.
And all other colors who had emergency, it would be a whole lot better in the county.
And so he was the one who recommended you for the course?
No, no, no, after.
You didn't recommend me for the course after I heard they were all fainting the course free.
And this was an opportunity.
Now we worked, we worked on the ambulance free.
You took the, they offered the course.
They paid for the course, but you had to work free.
And I worked on the ambulance, you know, getting up all the time of the night, day and night.
But until that free service went out, I worked until that free service went out on the ambulance and Baker County.
So what year did you start working with this?
Do you remember the year?
The course was offered in 1983, August, so 1983.
And it was six months course.
Okay.
And what was some of the encounters, what was some of the more memorable encounters that you had working with the MSB in the first black?
And how were you treated by the other, I imagine the other workers were white?
Did you ever?
No, no.
Now the workers, that was some very nice, you know, didn't discriminate and all.
And that was the kind of stood that distance.
But in all, they were, they were, they were, they were felonized about teaching me how to ride amolus and,
you know, certain things about the amolus and all of this.
Some of them was very nice.
Okay.
I can't really, is there any other thing about the Baker movement, about your involvement in it that you would like to share?
I really think I've not covered the most, the bloodest side that was one of those, was one of those most, most,
oh, but days you had ever heard of your life as seeing, you know, how they were just being people down to the ground.
And one of the ladies covered, Shiraz, by the, the keepin' from killing them, though they probably would have killed them.
That was Joseph Smith, I knew you heard that story when over again.
Now that was most, one of the most unjust sadadies that I could, could remember doing the movement time.
Back in, we remember one time that we marched from first press and grove about to stretch down to the courthouse to get some people registered to vote.
And this is it.
And I was shy of you, you heard it again.
Okay.
And he was down there that day and Shiraz was with us.
And when we, Anna, he told Shiraz that, you know, he wouldn't suppose to be there.
He was not a citizen, he was outside and you know, he was still to tellin' them, well we brought people here to get registered to vote.
And in a split second, he, he had been knocked him over in a corner.
And I was so afraid that, you know, he was going to kill him.
But he got up and he told him he had to leave.
And so we all left.
When he left, we all left and went back to the church.
But don't think that stopped us.
We were right back down there that next morning.
And we kept going till things got a little better about getting people registered.
You know, to vote.
When did you finally get registered?
I remember.
When did you finally get registered to vote?
Oh, I got registered.
But what doing this time?
During this time?
I got registered to vote.
Okay.
Doing this time.
Because I guess our, let me see, I was in, well I was married at that time.
But I guess I had not gotten registered to vote till they really start talking about it.
Because it was so complicated.
We thought, you know, all the questions they asked and everything.
But I got registered doing this time.
So did you took one of the literacy tests to get registered?
Did you have to take a literacy test?
Or did they just allow you to sign your names?
They allowed me at that time to sign.
Okay.
Yeah, I didn't have to take the literacy test.
I was here two years ago.
I heard several really appalling stories of like gay or just people.
Just incredible cruelty.
And I'm getting a man in the face of a young man in the face of the night state.
And the lawyer I think was King.
He had to go to the Make Sure He was getting some care and jail.
But I wonder what happened to all these people who got beaten up and injured.
You know, you hear about the, they had happened to what happened to the man who was injured.
What happened to the people?
Well, Alka, their injuries was, you know, they still, we still work with the movement.
And worked in Baker County still until we got people registered voting.
Thanks, got a LeComma.
He finally got a little bit calmer than he was at the beginning.
And that was, you know, people used to be afraid to even come to Baker County.
Because he was going to stop him and you surely was going to get a ticket.
You know, they would go around miles like Ron Camilla if they want to go to the Bainbridge to keep them coming to Baker County.
He was just, he was just a mean, he just was a mean man.
I can say, he had a service station and he put up signs and, you know, doing all of them demonstration and everything that he only wanted white business.
He didn't want black business.
But he finally, to Eel had, I don't know, he had a stroke or something.
And he stayed down for years before his death.
Oh, well, I say a separate one.
And that's how, you know, things kind of got a little better in Baker County.
Okay.
What about the people who are interested?
Did you have, did the movement help with medical care and stuff with people who got injured?
Did the movement help?
Oh, yes.
It really gave us the right to speak.
A lot of things, you used to couldn't help a white person.
Say it's something to you.
You weren't allowed maybe to say what you thought.
But now we speak freely, whether, you know, we speak freely and say things that we want to say, you know,
where we used to couldn't respond to them.
And you used to say anything to the white man.
You know, knock your down, hit you or kick you or do anything.
But now you have your speech on my speech.
That's one thing we have.
Freedom of speech and we really use it when it's necessary to speak our opinion.
Right.
And the movement helped.
It helped a lot.
It did because it helped to get people registered the boat, you know.
And the desegregation of the school gave people more courage and more wisdom to stand up for what arrived.
It helped a lot.
So I guess one of the questions I guess we're trying to get to is Dr. Shirley and this bloody Saturday again and the students coming in and needed to be treated.
How did they get their bills paid?
Did he charge them?
He did not charge them.
Okay.
He didn't worry about the charges for those that had gotten beaten up and bruised up.
That was his giving to the movement.
That's right.
That was his contribution.
Okay.
Yeah.
Well, I think you Ms. Louise Broadway for sharing your story with us.
We are very grateful that you were taking the time out and we appreciate it.
You're welcome.
I'm not going to go out.
You're going to get your microphone off and you'll be free to go to Rome to the hall.
Thank you.
Oh, the farm.
Yes, ma'am.
Thank you for sharing that sort of story.
You're welcome.
Thank you.
Take a bath.
This has been a presentation of the Library of Congress and the Smithsonian National Museum of African-American
History and Culture.